réseau les jeunes sont les pratiquants
évident et spontanée de la souris et du
clavier on peut donc parler d'une
génération internet au palais de la
découverte à paris un espace leur est
consacré est consacrée également au
multimédia et à ce réseau l'atelier
baptisé petit internaute reportage de
patricia charnelet et didier rancoeurs à
l'intérieur du palais de la découverte
ce lieu appelé cyber métropole consacré
au multimédia
le mercredi les enfants sont invités à
participer à une grande aventure devenir
internautes savoir naviguer sur le net
ils peuvent en quelques minutes
fabriquer leur propre page sur le réseau
informatique mondial
explications grâce à un appareil photo
numérique
leurs photographies enregistrait sur
disquette puis stockés dans l'ordinateur
l'enfant avec l'aide d'un animateur peut
alors créer son propre site
une sorte de fiche où ils se présentent
et dit ses goûts dès cet instant il peut
envoyer des messages et en recevoir du
monde entier
japon la chine si je rencontre quelqu'un
qui me paraît sympathique
j'ai dit bonjour je lui dis mon site je
parle un peu de vie me répondre une fois
le site personnel créé l'enfant ya accès
à partir de n'importe quel ordinateur ou
qu'ils soient ces petits internautes
font figure de pionniers
car notre pays tarde à s'équiper moins
de 2% des foyers français sont connectés
à internet des parents parlent beaucoup
les petits français le font et c'est
factuellement formidable de voir comment
les jeunes à partir de 5 ans ici quelque
chose pas trente six mille questions
n'essaie pas d'ouvrir le capot en
quelque sorte il se met devant
l'appareil devant l'ordinateur et pas la
souris il jouit des couilles fond des
choses pour mathieu clément et leurs
copains la possibilité de communiquer et
d'apprendre à l'échelle du monde est
aujourd'hui une réalité pour le prix de
l'entrée au palais de la découverte
17 francs ils sont devenus les
cybercitoyens exemple